the jurgen experience how often have you
shot a gun
a few times like all upstate new york i
should i mean i don't have a guy i
should get it i didn't think i'd need a
gun when i moved to l.a i didn't think
i'd have to sit by my i sit on my
balcony with a gun you know it seemed
relatively safe when i moved in people
were annoying but i didn't think they
were coming to kill me i didn't think
they were coming in my windows to kill
me but
now that i've now that i'm like yeah i
should get a gun yeah i think i texted
you second week of quarantine i'm like
i got a gun yeah you're one of them yeah
you're one of my liberal friends
i'm not a liberal friend but i was like
are you a centrist
i think i believe in pedophile cults and
lizard people i think that's centrist
i think that's in the center i'm on the
fence with lizard people but the
pedophile cults are real
they're all real i just don't care i
don't care
that's really my political option it's
like i i think
it's not most of it isn't real you're
making a lot of it real it's not real
walk away like it truly yeah like
the the like people that are real
activists
a lot of them have like a degree like
they're a lawyer or a doctor and then
they use
their skills to actually help people
right
and they give up really profitable
careers to do that [ __ ]
right but dude your twitter [ __ ]
posturing and your virtue signaling it
doesn't do anything
it's fake i know it's fake and there's
just more to life than red and blue
and republican or democrat and all these
[ __ ] are trying to kill you and
they're all [ __ ] losers
and they're all just i mean listen
they're more capable
like the all the [ __ ] that they've
pulled the cia all these people they're
just too good
they're good they've beat me they're
gonna win they're gonna win the cia's
gonna beat you maybe you should join
i don't know who needs to hear i'd love
to but i don't know who needs to hear
this
but like stop investing your emotional
all your emotions and your
your time and energy into this thing
like you would be so much better off if
you just found something you enjoyed and
did it
right but you don't want them taking
away your rights
and closing in on your email account
they're gonna do it anyway are they you
sure i'm gonna do
don't take my rice
they're gonna take them buy the gun do
whatever you got to do like
there there's no winning here do you
believe in a well-armed militia you
think that's necessary
yeah but look i mean you could yeah i'm
all for people having guns
but a militia like it seems like more
now than ever
the idea of forming a militia is in
people it's gonna happen
it'll happen there'll be skirmishes
there'll be violence in the street but
it's like
that's what i was most worried about
with portland seattle yeah at the end of
the day
you know i mean i don't know you know
this country is not designed for massive
reimagining that's sad to say
i can say it i'm a comedian it is what
it is but the reality is it's just not
it's gonna disintegrate like everything
else that's ever [ __ ] existent
on the planet and you just hope that it
the plane lands slowly and doesn't nose
dive into the ground
but the the best days are over here the
bright like the
the hopeful you know we're going to the
moon that's that's
done really you you don't think so
i think we could be in a little bit of a
blip when we make a nice resurgence in a
year and a half from now everything's
looking good i don't know i think we
just head into a dystopian
insane kind of like tech world where we
just all live on compute like reality
barely exists
no it's a real problem it's a dystopian
world we're heading into well the real
problem is if everything goes into like
a ready player one type situation where
whatever they can manufacture on a
computer with artificial reality is more
interesting
that's going to happen and listen most p
here's the problem most people
don't care they don't want these rights
they actually don't
you like them because you're like a
successful person most people don't give
a [ __ ] about their rights
they want pizza they want chicken wings
they want [ __ ] soda
they want cheap credit they want to go
on a cruise once a year
they don't give a [ __ ] about their
rights they don't care they want netflix
and they want you know garlic knots and
that's the
that's what it is and you could pretend
like america is just not a country
like freedom loving there's a few of
those people most people just like hey
whatever and
they're the happiest people a lot of
those people i'm talking about
are actually the happier people they're
not trying to build an empire
they're not trying to succeed they just
enjoy like putting something warm and
doughy in their mouth
vegging out and [ __ ] waking up the
next day and go [ __ ] i'm here again
and and they're the happiest people they
like to get drunk and go boating
that's it they like to get [ __ ] up and
go out on the lake
go out on the lake and get railed up and
yeah
and it's fun what are you gonna sit
around all day worry about what darpa's
doing it's like
what the [ __ ] kind of life is that grill
a burger it's over
i mean enjoy it it's the end the end's
not
that bad as ends go as
things as ends go this end happens to be
hilarious and there's still food in the
food stores
yeah that's a good point as of right now
i like your optimism this is a good end
it's not a bad end it's not the worst
end
[Applause]
you